la pédophilie une question bien délicate
à gérer dans l'église l'église n'a sans
doute pas été assez vigilante dans le
traitement des cas depuis que les
affaires de pédophilie ont éclaté
comment les autorités religieuses
gère-t-elle la situation tout a commencé
aux états unis là où les premiers
scandales ont été révélés en 1993 plus
de 400 prêtres étaient concernés c'est
un vrai problème parce que même si le
chiffre de 400 cas cité publiquement est
discutable
un abus est un abus de trop vieux
surtout lorsqu'ils touchent des enfants
le pape jean paul ii réagi dans une
lettre il autorise les cardinaux à
prendre des sanctions religieuse envers
les prêtres pédophiles
pour autant des diocèses tentent de
contourner la justice des hommes
exemple en 1994 dans le new jersey ils
font partie d'un groupe de 15 personnes
auxquelles le diocèse a versé en octobre
dernier un total de plus de 10 millions
de francs de dommages et intérêts sans y
être contraint par la justice
mais en échange de leur silence en
france aussi l'église tente de
dissimuler les agissements des prêtres
pédophiles
ils sont généralement transféré mais pas
révoqué et gare à ceux qui voudraient
briser la loi du silence dans ce collège
privé en bourgogne
quand la directrice a découvert des
photos à caractère pornographique
impliquant des élèves
elle a décidé de dénoncer le scandale et
a été licencié catholique
j'estime que mon devoir est de dénoncer
ce qui doit être dénoncé quand ça se
présente
les affaires de pédophilie dans l'église
sont médiatisés malgré tout le problème
est mondial dans les années 2000 le
vatican doit agir en 2002 jean paul ii
qualifie les abus de condamnable
puis en 2008 son successeur benoît 16
rencontres des victimes et présente ses
excuses
l'excusé jamais suffisant des excuses ça
répare pas tout et mai
faut passer par là pour le pardon
derrière des excuses des rencontres avec
des victimes et des prêtres de plus en
plus souvent révoqué à son tour le pape
françois demande pardon en 2016 et en
appelle à la justice des hommes
c'est à ce moment qu en france éclater
la sphère barbarin pour non dénonciation
d'actes pédophiles
un prêtre poursuivi pour des agressions
sexuelles sur de jeunes scouts
at il bénéficié du soutien de sa
hiérarchie
l'enquêté a été ouverte en 2016 et elle
est jugée en 2019
pour lons dénonciation il encourt trois
ans d'emprisonnement et 45000 euros
damende fin 2010 829 claire était mise
en cause dans des affaires de pédophilie
dont 10 ont été mises en examen
de son côté l'église française a
prononcé 49 suspension
[Musique]